[Música]
eu participo de concursos de beleza há
cinco anos em 2014 eu recebi meu
primeiro convite e eu confesso que eu
fiquei meio assim né porque eu assisto
concursos de beleza desde pequena mas na
minha cabeça concurso de beleza para
mulheres praticamente perfeitas e eu não
conseguia entender como eu poderia me
encaixar ali mas ao mesmo tempo eu
estava fazendo faculdade de jornalismo e
estava naquele momento que a gente não
sabe muito bem quem vai fazer depois da
faculdade né
eu queria te ver se eu queria escrever
não sabia da lei já que é uma
oportunidade nova eu sempre amei desafio
e vou me jogar ou não já tenho
e aí fui um mês depois eu ganhei meu
primeiro concurso de beleza
eu fui miss minas gerais mundo e aí
participei do miss brasil não vence mas
como os meus primeiros concursos eu
falei eu tenho experiência e eu acho que
eu posso ir mais longe gostei de ser
desafiada
falei eu vou continuar porque tem muita
gente que acha que concurso de beleza e
fútil e vazio mas eu garanto para vocês
que esses cinco anos transformaram a
júlia menina na mulher empoderada que
hoje fala aqui pra vocês eu participei
de mais seis concursos depois desse
primeiro eu estudava muitos concursos de
beleza porque eu achava que isso era a
fórmula eu assisti a todos eu ficava
vendo a passarela das vencedoras
o vestido que elas usavam a forma como
elas falavam porque eu sempre fui
cachorrona então achava que eu tinha que
estudar estudar muito e eu participei de
mais seis concursos e não vai em cima
óbvio porque é óbvio gente porque estava
olhando para o externo
eu estava o tempo inteiro olhando para
outras pessoas e tentando encaixar no
perfil que eu achava que existia ao
invés de olhar pra mim que a pessoa mais
importante da minha vida
e aí em 2017 e fui para a malásia
teoricamente teria sido meu último
concurso eu fui representar o brasil e
eu fiquei em quinto lugar e aí eu saí de
lá e falei assim meu deus eu nunca vou
ganhar um concurso de miss mas eu faço
tudo porque na minha cabeça e me
esforçar o máximo que eu podia
falei só nascer de novo pra ganhar um
concurso de beleza não tem mais jeito e
eu decidi que ia parar
eu falei eu sempre quis cortar meu
cabelo acho linda mulher de cabelo curto
e eu não cortava que mais uma vez eu
achava que mesmo não podia ter cabelo
curto
cortei o cabelo gente
coincidentemente ou não vocês podem até
achar bobeira mas o corte de cabelo
mudou minha vida
foi como se eu fosse uma borboleta
saindo do casulo sabe descobrir eu me
olhei no espelho falei gente que mulher
maravilhosa que mulher forte que mulher
corajosa
coincidentemente também na época eu
estava envolvido em autoconhecimento e
já meditava participei de vários
seminários
mas isso tudo me transformou e aí eu já
tinha ganhado certa visibilidade com os
concursos trabalhava como influenciador
edital na minha cidade
essa autenticidade que eu consegui
quando eu percebi quem eu era e me
ajudou a alavancar o meu trabalho
e aí eu juntei um outro sonho é isso eu
sempre quis e palestrante eu fiz
comunicação e jornalismo mas eu queria
falar para muita gente
eu falei já que tem muita gente que
também quer ser influenciador digital
vou criar um curso sobre isso então
comecei a falar a fazer palestras sobre
o tema
estava tudo fluindo estava muito feliz
muito satisfeita e aí chega um e mail
pra mim falando que eu tinha sido
selecionada para o miss minas gerais de
motion
para quem não sabe a miss minas gerais
de motion leva ao miss brasil de motion
que leva o mesmo universo que o concurso
mais conhecido do mundo
então isso era uma grande oportunidade
para mim
mas assim eu não sabia se eu queria
porque eu me inscrevi por acaso quando
eu vi um anúncio na internet mas eu
tinha muito medo porque eu tinha medo de
voltar a ser aquela júlia de antigamente
aquela júlia que estava encaixado em
padrão que era louca por dieta que
estava se comparando o tempo inteiro com
todo mundo e eu falei meu deus será que
eu tenho que fazer isso mas eu pensei eu
já trabalho com internet e esse concurso
vai me dar muita visibilidade
em segundo é uma forma de provar para
mim mesma que eu posso ser quem eu sou e
eu posso mostrar para o mundo quem é
essa júlia falei eu vou e todo mundo vai
conhecer a julia horta de verdade eu fui
do dia que eu fui selecionada é
promissor minas gerais até ser coroada
miss brasil foram 39 dias
e esse dia que foi o dia mais
funcionante da minha vida me fez
perceber uma coisa o quanto realmente o
autoconhecimento transforma o quanto
tudo que eu estava buscando por cinco
anos
o trl chance realizado justamente quando
eu descobri a mulher que eu realmente
era e é por isso que eu estou aqui hoje
porque eu sou miss brasil para quebrar
padrões
eu sou miss brasil justamente para
ressaltar essa importância do
autoconhecimento
eu sou miss brasil para apoiar outras
pessoas nesse processo de empoderamento
e aí eu trago para vocês também uma
reflexão sobre essa palavra que hoje em
dia a gente fala tanto sobre o
empoderamento mas o que que é
empoderamento porque tem muita gente que
acha que poderá muitas vezes está ligada
à estética uma posição de liderança né
a gente vê uma mulher no cargo de
liderança que anda em cima do salto
todos os dias maquiada a gente fala
nossa essa é uma mulher poderosa mas nem
sempre porque às vezes a mulher que está
do lado dela está com coragem de tênis e
óculos é muito mais poderosa que está
ali talvez tentando se encaixar no que
esperam que ela seja porque essa tem
coragem de ser quem ela é
é muito importante a gente o bate nessa
tecla mais uma vez que a gente tenha um
tempo pra gente olhar pra gente parar de
ficar olhando o tempo inteiro para as
outras pessoas que a gente acha incrível
e ver o quanto a gente incrível entender
as nossas dores
os nossos medos as nossas inseguranças o
que está travando a gente conquistar o
nosso sonho e qual é esse sonho foi
exatamente isso que aconteceu comigo
voltando ao o dia mais lindo da minha
vida que eu fui coroada miss brasil
eu ganhei foi um mix de emoções fui
dormir anestesiada e quando acordei no
outro dia eu sabia que eu tinha uma
responsabilidade muito grande porque eu
sabia que meu propósito ali era falar
para muita gente essa era a minha
vontade então tinha que fazer alguma
coisa de útil
falei que eu vou fazer na minha primeira
publicação como miss brasil
o meu está grande alavancado toda a
imprensa queria falar comigo eu falei
esse é o momento de falar de temas que
eu considero importantes e aí eu fiz um
vídeo e falei de sonoridade e feminismo
gente eu fui muito julgada muito
como é que pode uma
isso que participa de um concurso de
beleza se dizer feminista em primeiro
lugar como eu falei pra vocês eu sou
miss brasil que eu quero quebrar padrões
pode parecer bobo mas meu cabelo é um
deles
se vocês olharem os últimos 10 15 anos
os concursos de beleza aqui no brasil
quantas missões de cabelo curto existem
muitas mulheres tomaram coragem de
cortar o cabelo por causa do meu cabelo
e me deixa imensamente grata
eu apareci diariamente no instagram para
quem acompanha é sem maquiagem toda
suada
aposto tudo que eu como que nem sempre o
que as pessoas esperam mas porque eu
represento a mulher brasileira então
preciso ser real e além disso enquanto
várias missas que ganham os concursos né
e viram modelos trabalho em várias
campanhas desfiles
eu dou palestras não que os desfiles as
campanhas não sejam interessantes muito
pelo contrário também adoro mas eu vim
com esse propósito de impactar as
pessoas através da minha comunicação
então né gente eu sou mulher indignada
com o machismo com o patriarcado como
boi ana sempre arrumava briga quando eu
vi uma mulher sendo menosprezado só
porque ela era mulher me digo feminista
porque todos os direitos que nós
mulheres temos hoje foram conquistados
pelas feministas e tudo o que a gente
busca aí na luta com elas também
eu amo o direito que eu tenho de poder
estudar
eu amo direito de trabalhar eu amo meu
direito ao voto
eu amo poder falar o que eu quero passar
o que eu penso eu amo não tem que dar
satisfação da minha vida para o homem
nenhum
mas eu ainda detesto o assédio que eu
sofro todos os dias eu ainda detesto as
piadinhas machistas
eu detesto quando o homem me subestima
só porque eu sou mulher porque eu sou
bonita eu detesto quando virão pra mim
falar em julho
você precisa aprender lavar roupa para
uma casa que a casa um dia eu detesto eu
sou mulher e eu não quero ser igual aos
homens até porque isso é impossível
todos nós somos diferentes e eu amo ser
mulher e eu amo pluralidade dos seres
mas eu quero que haja equidade que
respeitando as diferenças que sim
existem entre nós
nós possamos ter oportunidades e
direitos iguais
eu sou mulher e eu não odeio os homens
muito pelo contrário eu amo vários deles
mas acredito que os homens têm que lutar
junto com a gente
talvez vocês não se sintam confortáveis
de se dizerem feministas
mas vocês podem apoiar o movimento e é
muito simples
respeitem as mulheres da vida de vocês
escutem como elas se sentem de
oportunidade para mulheres nas empresas
no trabalho onde vocês puderem criar os
seus filhos nos princípios da equidade
como assim se você tem um filho e uma
filha e vocês a mulher fizeram um almoço
de domingo juntos depois quando todo
mundo acaba de comer ao invés de jogar
bola com seu filho enquanto a sua filha
ajuda sua mulher a lavar louça façam
tudo juntos
isso transforma eu sou mulher sou
feminista e muito me entristece quando
eu então que todo meu lugar de fala
resolvo da visibilidade voz a esse
movimento tão importante
sou julgado por outras mulheres que se
dizem feministas
afinal de contas o feminismo não busca
que a gente tem o direito de fazer o que
a gente quiser fazer descer o que a
gente quer ser
então eu realmente não entendo e aí eu
trago então outro conceito muito
importante
a sonoridade a gente precisa lutar
juntas porque como que a gente quer que
alguém respeite a gente que alguém não
julgue a gente se quando qualquer coisa
acontece a primeira pessoa julgar uma
mulher é outra mulher
a sonoridade gente respeito e empatia
união entre as mulheres nós podemos
muito mais juntas
a sociedade criou essa competição que a
gente que existe entre nós e essa
competição excessiva gera uma
insegurança e quando a mulher quando uma
pessoa está insegura ela precisa falar
de outra para se sentir bem mas isso não
precisa acontecer nós mulheres podemos
nos tornar empoderadas ea partir daí em
poder a outras mulheres pelo exemplo e é
por isso que eu estou aqui hoje porque
desde que eu ganhei o miss brasil que
esse dever esse propósito falou muito
mais forte em mim
a necessidade de falar para o maior
número de pessoas que eu puder do quanto
é importante a gente descobrir quem a
gente realmente é o que a gente tem
especial que pode apoiar outras pessoas
realmente
a gente só tem sucesso na nossa vida
quando a gente consegue encontrar aquilo
que a gente é especial
a partir dessa característica que todos
nós temos apoio a outras pessoas
e aí que realmente a gente tem nosso
sucesso financeiro o nosso sucesso
econômico a partir do momento que eu
entendi que beleza é um conceito
subjetivo e que ela não é só aparência
eu parei de me concentrar na rivalidade
com as mulheres incríveis que estariam
comigo num concurso de beleza eu
consegui passar a admirar essas mulheres
também porque eu conhecia a história
delas
afinal de contas como eu já falei outras
vezes aqui todos nós somos diferentes
então eu era incrível mas elas também
eram incríveis então que na noite final
ganhasse que tivesse que ganhar porque
eu também acredito muito nisso as coisas
acontecem quando elas têm que acontecer
e aí gente um exemplo pra mim essa
sonoridade que eu falei acontecendo no
concurso
foi quando no dia da final eu me juntei
com algumas amigas que eu fiz no miss
brasil
e a gente começou a pensar em possíveis
respostas para possíveis perguntas que
fizessem pra gente
afinal de contas não ia cair a mesma
pergunta para duas meninas
então por que não a gente ter resposta
excelente todas nós brilhar mas na hora
de responder às perguntas
isso pra mim foi maravilhoso poder ter
essa conexão com elas e realmente também
torcer por elas
fez com que eu ficasse leve e aí o
resultado foi uma júlia 100% julho na
passarela e agora a oportunidade de
falar para milhares de pessoas inclusive
vocês
isso é parte do meu propósito o meu
propósito é através da comunicação
impactar o maior número de pessoas
possível de uma forma positiva
comunicar para mim transforma então hoje
aqui se eu tiver conseguido plantado no
coração de cada um ou pelo menos de 1
a sementinha da sonoridade do feminismo
mas principalmente do respeito de
empatia
eu estou cumprindo meu propósito e vou
sair daqui realizada
muito obrigada
o tom